au moment où je viens défendre devant
vous le budget de la Sécurité sociale je
veux une nouvelle fois rendre hommage
aux soignants
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour partout en France ils sont
au côté de nos compatriotes fragiles ou
malades il lutte sans cesse et son prêt
à tout donner pour prendre soin pour
soulager pour guérir nous leur devons
des moyens à la hauteur de leur
engagement c'est pourquoi le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale augmente le budget de la santé
de près de 9 milliards d'euros en 2023
c'est 43 milliards d'euros de plus par
rapport à 2019 avant la pandémie
mais pour la France insoumise et le
rassemblement national quelle est la
réponse pour les soignants les patients
et notre hôpital la censure
aujourd'hui je pense aux personnes âgées
en perte d'autonomie et à leur famille
nous devons être solidaires avec elle
préparer la transition démographique et
offrir à chacun la possibilité de bien
vieillir chez soi c'est pourquoi le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale prévoit d'augmenter le
nombre de salariés dans les services à
domicile et d'instaurer deux heures
supplémentaires d'accompagnement et de
hebdomadaire et pour les aînés en EHPAD
ce texte renforce la présence soignante
à leur côté et les moyens de contrôle
des établissements mais pour la France
insoumise et le rassemblement national
quelle est la solution pour les
personnes âgées la censure
aujourd'hui on m'adressant à vous je
pense à tous nos compatriotes dont les
maladies seront détectées plutôt ou
éviter grâce à un renforcement sans
précédent de nos actions de prévention
la prévention c'est un tournant
fondamental et un grand pas pour
l'égalité les déterminismes sociaux sont
encore bien souvent à l'oeuvre face à la
maladie les rendez-vous de prévention
aux âges clés de la vie c'est une
manière de les déjouer mais pour la
France insoumise et le rassemblement
national quelle est la réponse aux
inégalités de santé la censure
la liste est encore longue je pense au
mersol dont nous allons faciliter la
garde d'enfants je pense aux personnes
en situation de handicap pour qui nous
investissons davantage je pense aux
jeunes femmes qui bénéficieront de la
contraception d'urgence gratuite et face
à tous ces défis quelle est la réponse
l'unique réponse de la France insoumise
et du rassemblement national la censure
mesdames et messieurs les députés si dès
son dépôt le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
proposée de nombreux progrès vous l'avez
profondément améliorer et enrichi en
commission le travail conjoint et la
volonté de co-construction ont permis
l'adoption du texte dans son intégralité
en séance l'esprit de responsabilité a
souvent prévu et nous avons d'ailleurs
conservé dans le texte que j'ai proposé
la quasi-totalité des amendements votés
plus de 150 amendements
[Applaudissements]
alors ce projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale montre une fois de
plus que le compromis et souhaitable et
qui n'est même possible et que le débat
parlementaire quand il est mené deux
bonnes foi conduit à des progrès
concrets nous avons retenu des
propositions de la majorité comme des
oppositions grâce à votre travail nous
allons mieux lutter contre les
difficultés d'accès aux soins avec le
cumul emploi retraite pour les médecins
avec un meilleur partage des tâches
entre les professionnels de santé avec
un accès simplifié à la complémentaire
santé solidaire grâce à votre travail le
contenu des rendez-vous de prévention a
été précisé selon les priorités que vous
avez établies la santé mentale la santé
des femmes le cancer l'activité physique
le repérage des violences sexuelles et
sexistes grâce à votre travail les
personnes atteintes de cancer pourront
être intégralement remboursé des
prothèses cap grâce à votre travail les
droits sociaux ont été améliorés pour
les enfants victimes de pesticides in
uteraux grâce à votre travail les
sanctions contre les EHPAD qui ne
respectent pas les demandes les demandes
des autorités de contrôle seront
renforcés grâce à votre travail le congé
prochainement et le congé de présence
parentale pour les parents d'enfants
malades ont été améliorés toutes ces
mesures sont des avancées pour nos
concitoyens ce texte a été construit
avec vous nourri par vos discussions et
vos débats en commission commencez
ce texte a été amélioré grâce à vous
parce que vos idées et vos votes ont été
pris en compte ce texte démontre que
nous sommes déterminés à répondre à
l'attente des Français qui veulent du
dialogue et la recherche de compromis et
je regrette que certains face à un texte
d'avancer social face à un texte
considérablement enrichi grâce au débat
parlementaire n'est qu'une chose vous
proposer une chose à opposer censurer le
gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés comme
la semaine dernière sur le projet de loi
de finances de motion de censure ont été
déposés mais aujourd'hui les signataires
diffèrent peut-être faut-il y voir le
signe que pour plusieurs groupes la
responsabilité et le progrès valent
mieux que le blocage du pays
les 12 orateurs s'arrangent le droit de
parler du peuple comme si eux seuls
savaient ce que vivent nos concitoyens
avec condescendance pour leurs collègues
parlementaires c'est une chose mais
qu'on descendance aussi pour les
Français eux-mêmes qu'il est si simple
de cataloguer avec une rhétorique éculée
et qui derrière les mots nous propose
aucune solution si ce n'est la
préférence nationale d'un côté et une
version anachronique de la lutte des
classes de l'autre
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés de la
France insoumise votre stratégie dans
les faits conduit à refuser aux Français
des progrès sociaux parce qu'ils sont
proposés par le gouvernement
[Musique]
j'ai toujours dit que je ne confondais
pas que je ne vous confondais pas avec
le rassemblement national mais quand
votre grand leader à l'extérieur de
cette émission présente sur son blog la
méthode pour rendre un texte de censure
acceptable sur tous les bancs et fait
les comptes sans séparer vos voix et
celle de l'extrême droite je ne peux que
constater que vous entretenez la
confusion
[Applaudissements]
car au fond pour vous la fin justifie
tous les moyens même une alliance contre
nature de celle qui nourrit les
populismes et dont l'histoire nous a
appris qu'elles finissait toujours par
favoriser l'extrême droite mesdames et
messieurs les députés de la France
insoumise la nouvelle union des
populistes ne construit pas de majorité
alternative mais cela aussi vous faites
semblant de l'ignorer une chose est
pourtant claire le progrès ne viendra
pas de l'instabilité et du chaos votre
motion de censure une fois de plus
enchaîne les outrances et les
contre-vérités vous demandez des moyens
pour l'hôpital c'est dans le projet de
loi vous voulez des mesures pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux et améliorer
l'accès aux soins c'est dans le projet
de loi Vous demandez une augmentation
globale du budget de la Sécurité sociale
c'est dans le projet de loi
votre motion de censure c'est finalement
le député Olivier Faure qui en parle le
mieux et je le cite c'est du brouhaha
et dans son texte le rassemblement
national affirme franchement
frontalement brièvement aussi ça pue et
simple volonté d'obtenir le rejet du
projet de loi et la chute du
gouvernement cela ne me surprend pas le
rejet du progrès et le conservatisme
sont inhérents à votre histoire vous
n'acceptez jamais un texte qui offre des
moyens et des solutions car votre
sécurité sociale à vous ce sont les
difficultés de nos concitoyens
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés dès le
départ les oppositions avaient indiqué
qu'elle rejetterait le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
s'il vous plaît pour autant le projet de
loi a été adopté en commission pour
autant les débats dans l'émission ont
été de qualité nos discussions ont été
utiles elles ont nourri le texte Michel
Rocard le disait devant cette assemblée
le 49-3 permet de conclure un débat
jamais de l'interdire
[Musique]
j'entends les oppositions qui peuvent
légitimement penser que voter un texte
financier reviendrait à une approbation
plus large de la politique du
gouvernement mais je veux retenir que
sur ce texte nous n'avons pas été loin
d'un accord pas loin de répondre à
l'attente des Français construire des
compromis sans compromission ce projet
de loi propose des acquis sociaux
majeurs nous resterons ouverts au
dialogue au Sénat comme en nouvelle
lecture et nous restons déterminés à
agir au service des Français je vous
remercie